and then there's twitter's
obnoxious policy of deciding
um you know for example that
um that covid19 that sars cove
ii is inherently
that the consent the scientific
consensus that it is a natural virus
that emerged
from bats is so secure that we can
declare
anything that doesn't adhere to this
consensus
as um a kind of
um unforgivable thought that it will
label things
yeah right um what that does is it tamps
down
the fact that you've got lots of people
who are looking at
the facts even just the basic facts and
saying that doesn't add up and there's
this other
hypothesis that does add up and it
doesn't seem like we know enough to know
which origin it has yeah so well and
that's what it's kind of funny kind of
the gateway drug to censorship in a lot
of cases are
conspiracy theories and i take two
different approaches to that as being a
free speech person who isn't
particularly
bothered you know by this is one even if
they're false conspiracies move the
world and it's important to know what
people really think full stop
this this is this is my free speech
radicalism it comes down to something
very simple
it's always important to know what
people really think period
and so for example like we would have
such a poor understanding
of of where the anti-semitism came from
before world war ii if we didn't
understand
the the protocols of zion it'd be being
this huge
you know uh fraud and hit
but understanding like people's paranoia
and superstitions all of the stuff
it is is um is so incredibly important
but also the other part is there's
always a possibility that it could be
true
um and i mean given you know my family
had to flee the soviets you know um
it's just one conspiracy after the other
so this is funny brett
this room doesn't think i'm here so i
occasionally have to do this
[Laughter]
well maybe you should just take up
gesticulating as a more central part of
your
communication modality oh i'm actually
really tampering it down right now
this is the one that i seem to do for
everything according to my wife
uh it's it's an atom or the galaxy
or it you know like there's so many
things that actually it's like well this
is going to happen and it's like
yeah i do it without even realizing it
it's arguments in 2020
yeah right there's a certain roundness
to that argument
there is a certain that was a favorite
law school professor uh said that one
time
trying to be nice um but i thought that
was great
so let me uh take you back to two things
you just said here
cool um one i want to talk to you about
conspiracy theories
yes um because i feel like we're missing
the boat on this one okay
great there is a very obvious way to
deal with conspiracy theories and that
is not to traffic in them
right but there's a way to deal with the
possibility of true things
and it just so happens that we have the
most excellent system you could possibly
want for dealing with them which is
science
so i want to be very clear and i have
been very clear with my audience
that theory has a precise meaning
that means it has withstood rigorous
tests there should only ever be one
theory at a time right that is to say
the theory of natural selection
is the theory of natural selection
because we have so thoroughly tested it
and there is no competitor
right before it was tested it was a
hypothesis
and so i would say the responsible way
to deal with the conspiracy issue is to
say
these are hypotheses the fact that one
advances a hypothesis doesn't mean you
even believe it's true
right you can have all kinds of
hypotheses this you know
our conversation could be taking place
in
a simulated universe i don't believe
that's true but i do regard it as a
hypothesis
and to the extent that it makes
predictions it's testable so
so i think the point is we have been
sold a bill of goods we've been led
into a dangerous territory by
thinking in terms of conspiracy theories
when in fact they are hypotheses they
make predictions and we can treat them
exactly as seriously as you would
a proposed scientific idea that hasn't
been tested or
um has you know given mixed results
well here's why you get in trouble brad
thought experimentation devil's advocacy
are absolutely essential to the
production of ideas
and i say this stuff on campus and
people are like what people have to take
the other side of different arguments
i'm like
yeah actually ideally you'd have someone
who actually believes the other side of
the argument because they're going to
know the most arguments for it and
they're going to be able to
they're going to be able to um to defend
it but if not someone in your team
should pretend
that they are willing to throw out these
other hypotheses
on what actually happened and i'm seeing
i'm seeing a situation on campus where
that's been sort of
obliquely threatened and now it's being
very directly threatened we just had a
case of st
john's where a professor do you know do
you know this one brad
i don't think so this is a this is a
case where a professor was
um in a history class was talking about
um the colombian exchange you know
the uh all the wonderful things that the
rest of the world got from columbus's uh
quote-unquote discovering the new world
and of course that includes things as
basic as
potatoes and tomatoes like that alone
would have made it an incredibly
important um exchange but this is a
serious historical question kind of like
for all the horrors that came out of the
um the triangle slavery and all this all
the the um
uh and the murder and the exposure to
smallpox and all these horrible things
the question is you know was it worth it
any serious intellectual any serious
student should be able to go
huh you know and and puzzle through that
and come down be able to come down on a
side
but it's treated in this case so much
like heresy
that the professor was suspended um
at st john's and i think this i think he
still is um he was relieved from
teaching and and i'm seeing
more and more cases because a lot i saw
a ton of cases for years
whereas professors saying something on
twitter that would get them in trouble
absolutely free speech issue absolutely
important but it's moving closer and
closer to the classroom
although you might know something about
that well yes i
it does seem to me i encountered
something a few years back i'll see if i
can remember what it was yeah
but okay so i totally agree with this
thought experiment
is an essential tool right and the
ability to voice a thought experiment
even an obnoxious thought experiment
right is part and parcel of how
you know we do moral philosophy among
other things i mean trolley problems
right if you couldn't talk
trolley problems because you're killing
innocents well then you know you're
robbed of this important uh tool for for
the advancement of uh
of ethics but um okay so
we um well i want to i want to take you
back to that second thing before we
lose the thread sure sure so you are
very skeptical about top-down
solutions to our online problem you
agree that we are
dealing with very dangerous downstream
consequences of technologies that we
couldn't foresee the hazard
yeah as they were invented so that some
sort of precaution were it possible
might have saved us from that but maybe
no
conceivable precaution could have
existed
but here's the question isn't the
solution for online
an upgrade to our
constitutional protections that have
worked so well for speech in other
realms uh so like uh
what would that look like well i think
it would look like exactly what you have
just described which is
a radical commitment to keeping the
space
open to ideas including obnoxious ones
because the consequence of trying to
shut it down and leaving only
respectable ideas
is unthinkably terrible on very short
time scales
yeah and that's been that's been my and
people like david french's argument that
essentially if you're going to
start regulating speech guess what you
have this absolutely brilliant body and
and i'm i'm the obnoxious american my my
my
mother's british irish my father grew up
in yugoslavia but is russian
um and you know you're taught from a
pretty early age not to go over there
with
thinking your values are superior but i
totally break that norm when i go to
other countries and talk about first
amendment
because i and and i have and what i
explain is i know you guys think we're
nuts but
in this country you know any practically
any country in europe
you're going after speech because it
someone finds it offensive
in our country one of the major
differences between us and everybody
else
is actually relatively small but it's
that we have a bedrock principle that it
can never be
merely because someone finds it
offensive that doesn't make cultural
sense that
these norms change from period to period
they're different from from economic
class economic class from nation to
nation from
men to women that it in some cases so
the principles that actually are
have been thought out by frankly some of
the best minds um
in in us history i mean you know oliver
wendell holmes and
louis brandeis were were no slouches on
this stuff
and that it presents this really
sensible body of of of law
um and actually philosophy and how you
actually deal
deal with speech and i think that would
be ideal um
way to regulate speech to use those
standards regulate speech on the
internet
i can't quite bring myself though to
want to give up the freedom of
association
and expressive rights that these
companies have in the first place
but i do think that if there was if
there was a place that
actually applied these rules um it would
be
and applied them very uh very firmly it
would be
a healthier environment for one um even
though there'd be some nastiness of
course
to be expected but the direction that um
twitter and facebook are currently going
i think that it's going to start looking
like the absurdities that you see
uh in in europe and and worse it's going
to also
involve things and and you know one of
the reasons why nobody wants to even
do the thought experimentation what if
this actually was a biological weapon
well because of the power wealth and
influence of china
well that's true i should say just point
of clarity
um that it was a biological weapon is a
hypothesis
and i assume that and the funny thing is
i know people on the on the interwebs
would would be like well
you claim this and i'm like yeah no it's
a i i totally understood his hypothesis
it's a high point well that wasn't the
one
that so i personally believe um the most
robust hypothesis we don't have a theory
of its origin yet we really don't know
but the most robust hypothesis
is a lab leak but not a weapon yeah this
was
a virus that had picked up
capacities through what's called gain of
function research
and then escaped presumably it infected
a
a worker and would have gotten out that
way though that's not the only path but
in any case these are competing
hypotheses
right i haven't seen any support yet for
the
bio-weapon hypothesis though it's a
hypothesis whether there's any evidence
for it or not the point is
right were it true it would it would uh
make certain predictions about the way
it behaved
well the whole time bomb aspect of it
the ability to um transmit
asymptomatically and then you get wallet
by it
um you know two weeks later is that's
clever
and that's definitely one of the reasons
why i think people think it
you know sometimes go to it being a
weapon is it's just so perfectly
designed to spread
well i would say that's not a prediction
though that is an observation
of its nature which leads to the
hypothesis right
it could be a bio weapon in which case
it would have to have
other features but
but in any case i guess my only point is
it just so happens that we have
the most robust system ever devised
i believe the most robust system
possible for figuring out what's true
and it's already the bedrock of western
civilization
why do we exclude conspiracies from
its application why do we leap to
calling these things theories rather
than start with the idea that they're
hypotheses
you know and you know to your point
about thought experiments
the beauty of this system is that it is
a formal feature of it that the fact
that you are
advancing an explanation for something
and positing
predictions that would come from that
explanation has nothing to say about
whether you believe it's true
right in fact when you're working
scientifically the right thing to do is
to generate as many hypotheses to
explain an observation as you can
and then test to see which of them is
correct which means that you've got
simult you've simultaneously advanced
mutually exclusive ideas that's part of
the
part of the nature of the work and so if
we simply brought the discipline
of this hypothetical deductive thinking
to
questions of conspiracy and collusion
we free ourselves from the madness that
happens when
you know even voicing a conspiracy is
now taken to be an embrace of it and
that is taken to be a sign of some sort
of
mental failure
[Music]
you